California is a beautiful state the
mountains the ocean the desert its
entertainment its agriculture and
high-tech output and the envy of the
world and California it seems to have it
all I first came here thirty years ago
as a college student and thought wow
people actually live like this this is
paradise but let's face it the Golden
State has changed a lot over the past
three decades and a lot of that change
frankly has been for the worse and a lot
of it has been caused by disastrous
liberal policies taxes have gone up and
up regulations have stifled small
business creation illegal immigration
has exploded here Jerry Brown called
California a sanctuary state electricity
prices are climbing because of stupid
government mandates the mandatory $15
minimum wage is hurting low-income
workers because more retailers are now
moving to automation to save the money
and we've seen a major squeeze on
California's middle class as the number
of working poor is growing California's
public pension systems are about two
hundred billion dollars in the red oh
and while homelessness nationwide is
declining it's up here by three percent
by the way sheltering and caring for the
homeless cost taxpayers an estimated
eighty thousand dollars per person per
year in fact it's so bad that some of
the major cities like San Francisco
Sacramento and right here in the Los
Angeles area now have what they call
permanent tent cities or encampments and
it's all the homeless like this one that
popped up not far from some of the
wealthiest ZIP codes in the country
do you think that the problem with
homelessness has gotten worse over the
past five years in Los Angeles worse
it's getting worse there's so much
people over woman
they keep growing and growing like I all
notice them in different spots not just
here this is one of the bigger ones and
then Skid Row but there's little spots
alongside of all the freeway entrance
do you think that the that the city
government here cares I don't think so I
don't think so I think they would rather
make us disappear and to be near that
building over there which is City Hall
the city government in Los Angeles is
all Democrats do you fit and they
haven't done anything do you think it's
time for a change
yeah and it's sad because I'm also own
Democrat too I'm also a Democrat it's a
shame I'm shameful these people that
they're treating us like this
I've even contacted a lot of the
Senators about the lives situation down
here and alls I get is that we'll get
back with you and as a fellow Democrat I
think they need to really look at what's
going on cuz I even told him I'm a
Democrat and I voted for them so why do
I have to wait this long city
governments failed you
yeah and the city governments run by
which party
[Music]
amazing well it has been run by
Democrats basically a supermajority
Democrat state this beautiful gorgeous
amazing place has been brutalized by
decades of liberal policies
I've course the sanctuary status high
taxation crippling environmental
regulations liberalism has ruined a once
I'd illustrate state in many ways
now there's an exodus of out of
California and while the population
continues to reelect wave after wave of
liberal leaders that only compound the
state's crisis joining us now with
reaction from Los Angeles is Shirley
hussar who's a CEO of urban GameChanger
chant changers an urban community
activist group along with clay Kane a
democratic activist clay and Shirley
great to see both of you clay let's
start with you why is this working
Democratic policies in Los Angeles just
focus on LA for a moment we won't go up
to the problems in San Francisco but you
heard from the homeless people in that
piece that it's gotten worse under
Democrat leadership they're living in
the tents well Laura listen um I have
been homeless I was homeless as a
teenager so this is a very personal
story to me but I think it really
minimizes the story to just look at just
Democrats I mean when you look back at
this this goes back to the early 1980s
it's a very complicated issue you have
drug addiction that was never dealt with
to say that all this is just a
democratic issue would be like blaming a
state like Mississippi which is the
poorest state in the country on
Republicans because it's a red state I
think it's unfair to do and it minimizes
the true horror the people go through
who or who are homeless I can relate to
this
surely the issue of illegal immigration
which we didn't delve into much in this
piece but from the time that I've walked
those same tents there's a lot of
illegal immigrants who are homeless as
well they come here they try to get jobs
sometimes they can't find jobs and they
don't have any sponsors or families to
live with and so they live among the
homeless that is also a big problem for
this state of California and you've been
spent enormous amount of time in these
permanent encampments yes absolutely I
tell you Laura the infrastructure of
California is being destroyed is being
demised by Jerry Brown Kevin de Leon and
Eric Garcetti they have personally
instructed the police officers not to
enforce law to allow the illegal
immigrants to do so much to cause so
much damage in the homelessness look
we've had money in this state you're
talking about a state that you can't
compare this to Mississippi come on clay
let's get real California at one point
we were the fifth largest economy in the
world we're still in the top ten so you
have a state that's in the top ten of
the economy and yeah no let me finish
because of the financial issues that are
going on in this state there's a
misappropriation of funds we have
hepatitis A we have measles going on we
have Laramie disease that just happen
over at Disneyland we have San Diego
that just spent two million dollars
towards sanitation of the homelessness
the homelessness in California is
disrupted because of the illegal
immigration and the misappropriation of
movement of money within this state
Democrats have failed this state and
they continue to fail this straight
they're destructive with their
governmental programs that filtrate
within their pockets they have killed
our community surely surely with all due
respect according to your bio with early
with cording to your bio you worked for
Governor Schwarzenegger who put
Calliphora and put California in an
actual bankruptcy so I mean it's not
just Democrats I mean that that was
somebody that you actually worked for
and there has been no documentation no
proof that anybody is homeless because
of because of undocumented workers I
wasn't homeless undocumented workers I
was homeless because because of because
of render rents were too high my mother
didn't have access to good health care
my mother didn't have access to good
good education it was not because of
undocumented workers and for you to say
that it is scapegoating it's offensive
you know you know you know there was no
one who was homeless because of an
undocumented worker that is ridiculous
work you guys we're gonna have you both
back because this is ridiculous amount
of short time for this I think what
Shirley was trying to say though
as long as we have a single American
homeless a veteran homeless a family
homeless living on the streets why are
we bringing in more problems I think
that's what she was saying not that hope
not that illegal immigrants we don't
know I totally disagree that that's a
scapegoat a smokescreen and if the guys
guys stop so so what clay is saying is
that we should bring in more in it's
different policies you can create it
took to blame on undocumented workers
passing above and it's a they have no
infrastructure
yeah wrong I think ending early
who put California
[Laughter]